el último y más agresivo rebrote ha
devuelto el coronavirus a su presunta
cuna las autoridades han informado hoy
de siete casos locales en luján que
parece muy pocos para una ciudad de 11
millones pero que han bastado para que
se ordene que todos ellos sean testados
en los próximos días también se ha
ordenado el cierre de escuelas y se
exige la toma de temperatura y el código
verde en el teléfono a la entrada de
centros comerciales y supermercados y
janes en el mundo solo el origen de la
pandemia pero en china también simboliza
la lucha más eficaz contra la pandemia y
se explica que las medidas tomadas hoy
sean contundentes incluso para los
parámetros nacionales sus ciudadanos
pasaron en el origen de la pandemia 79
días encerrados y hasta esta mañana
sumaban un año sin contagios locales
debido a su extrema precaución los
metros hoy volvían a ir semi vacíos y
algunos habían corrido a las tiendas
para aprovisionarse de víveres china ha
informado hoy de 90 casos son ya una
decena de provincias las afectadas por
el rebrote que nació dos semanas atrás
en el aeropuerto de nanjing cuando uno
operarios limpiaron un avión llegado de
rusia las autoridades explican que este
rebrote es más difícil de atajar porque
detrás está la variante delta mucho más
contagiosa que las anteriores